- Freeze! police.
Hands up.
Turn around slowly.
Okay, buddy.
Do not move a muscle.
Up! Up!
Get your hands back up.
No, raise them.
Up, hands up, now!
No, no stop!
I said no moving.
Put your foot down.
That's good.
Now, easy does it. No!
Don't pick your other foot up!
Put that down.
Put your foot down!
Put your foot down.
There we go.
No, do not
pick the other one up.
Put that one down.
Put your foot down.
no, not--
Put them both down
at the sa--okay.
Now you're just walking.
Stop walking!
Now!
St--no walking!
I want you to stop walking
right now.
Do not get near that car.
Wait, get away from it.
No, don't go near that car.
Don't open that door!
Do not open that door!
Don't open it.
Do not open the car door!
Don't you open that door.
Don't! Do not get in that car.
Freeze!
Your butt better not
hit that seat.
The--okay.
stay--do--get out of there.
Get out of the car right now.
No, you don't.
Don't you dare reach
for that glove compartment.
Don't reach for that
glove compartment!
Get away
from the glove compartment!
Get your hand away
Don't you open it!
Do not grab that gun!
Whatever you do, dude,
you better not grab that gun.
You better not
grab that gun.
[panting]
Do not pull that gun on me.
Put that down!
Don't you pull that gun on me.
No, hey. put that down.
Don't do it!
Damn it! God damn it!
[engine starts]
Damn it. Not again.